coronavirus how bad is it how real is
that how word should you and I be I mean
the feds just dropped the race to zero
on the last one we did this was an oh
wait right before a potential depression
it was already a recession and the time
before 2008 was in 1952 so should you
and I be worried you may be a parent a
family member as somebody that's running
a business and entrepreneur entrepreneur
you want to know more we don't have all
the time in the world to sit there
researching for hours on Saturday I came
to the office from morning till night I
was researching and in today's video
we're going to talk about the timeline
of what it led to where we are today
we're going to talk about cases in the
country's death in countries by state
the main concern that we have with
hospital beds on where we rank versus
other countries how infectious this
disease is and the death rate and in 10
people you ought to follow on final
thoughts I'm going to have about the
coronavirus pretty sure to stay till the
end because there's a link I want to
share with you that's going to give you
this information on a daily basis you
can be updated on what's going on what
sources to follow but having said that
you know yesterday I was in
communication with so many different
people I'd say four or five hundred
people through text or phone call till
one o'clock in the morning and the
conclusion I come up with that there are
five different types of people with the
topic of Crona virus and the first kind
of the naive folks these are folks that
don't really know what's going on
they're just innocently lymon their
lives they're kind of worried a little
bit because everybody else is worried
but they're not grabbing paper on
finding out what's going on the second
kind or those that are probably the
biggest threat to what's going on today
these are folks that are ignorant they
don't really do any research they don't
know what's going on but they have
opinions because they hear something
from here on a meme or social media post
or something they read over here and
they're just kind of blurred it out on
what's going on then the third kind
already responsible people these are
people that know what's going on but
they're not making the right responsible
decisions the fourth kind or those that
are into conspiracy theories let me tell
you it's China let me tell you it's this
let me tell you stay US government tell
you this because it's more of a juicy
story they just want to kind of share
these are people that love gossip and
they want to share this stuff with other
people and the fifth kind or those that
are the critical thinkers that don't
want to listen to somebody talk and
sensationalize what's going on they want
to do research and they want to go see
data and I want to see what the experts
are saying today I'm sharing
with you what these experts are talking
about so the goal is by the time you're
done you're living a busy life you can
say okay I kind of have an idea what's
taking place with this so let's go
through the timeline and everything I
talked about I want to leave the links
below for you to go take a look at first
things first on December 31st China
alerts whi which is a World Health
Organization of a flu like case in Juan
right we don't really know much about it
right now but at least they alerted them
on January 1st
Wuhan market identified as the outbreak
hub on January 5th
w-h-o World Health Organization advises
against travel restrictions again
against not for it the same ones that
said this is a pandemic advised against
travel restrictions because they were
not yet too worried about it
January 6 SARS MERS and bird flu ruled
out January 11th first death reported 61
year old man went to the hospital on the
27th of December he thought he had flu
he ends up dying On January 11 January
13 first confirmed case outside of China
in Thailand January 17 second death 69
year old man from Wuhan January 21st us
is first Crona virus case in Washington
30 year old man who traveled back from
China January 22nd w-h-o declares
international health emergency okay now
they're taking a little bit more
seriously January 23rd China implements
travel ban to and from Wuhan one's a
pretty big place pretty big city dole
who big communities around 50 million
people so that's a pretty big deal day
announced right there January 29 death
toll touches 132 five thousand nine
hundred seventy four cases infected
right January 30th Russia closes 2700
mile border to China January thirtieth
Russia already said no one can come here
from China February 2nd trump announces
travel ban to and from China February 7
Chinese whistle blower doctor who tried
to issue early warning dies of
coronavirus let me say this again this
doctor he's worried that this could be
bigger than what they think it is but
Chinese government is trying to prevent
him he's a whistleblower he comes on and
says you guys got to be worried about
this the same doctrines of dying
death told hit 638 February 11th w-h-o
gives name coronavirus COBIT 19 February
19th death toll hits 2,000 fabric
22nd Italy reports death 78 year old man
Iran reports to that February 27 Iranian
VP is officially testing positive for
the coronavirus February 29 u.s.
officially reports the first death and
Trump announces travel ban to and from
Iran March 30,000 death toll
waho staff member test positive this
next one's very interesting on March 3rd
Iran releases 54,000 prisoners to
prevent spread of the virus 54,000
prisoners go ahead you're free this is a
way of us trying to prevent the virus
because everybody's in prison together
March 9 Italian Prime Minister imposes
countrywide lockdown us death toll hits
26 March 11th this is a big day w-h-o
declares the outbreak of pandemic and
Trump extends to travel ban to and from
Europe March 12 Italy's death toll hits
1,000 in Italy in Trump on March 13
declares national emergency death toll
hits 5500 today cases hundred 73,000
death toll 6664 by the time you watch
this this numbers increasing
the daytime shooting this is Monday
March 16th is the date today so you can
go back and look at the date so if you
see it on another attire today for you
to know how fast it's escalating so I'm
showing this stuff to you how bad has a
gun of would events so many events have
been canceled South by Southwest Ultra
Music Festival Miami Boston Marathon NBA
NHL MLB masters MLS Coachella Adobe Ted
20/20 f8 which is the biggest Facebook
conference of the Year GDC which is a
Game Developers Conference shopify
courts jury duty I can give you many
apples shut down all their stores so
many different things that are taking
place I'm surprised the Olympics Japan
hasn't yet made any announcement because
what country in the next four or five
months is gonna feel comfortable sending
their people to Olympics not many are so
this announcements probably coming soon
you may watch us in May and say they've
already announced it then that's great
because today is March 16th ok so having
said this what what is the concern what
if what if some of the biggest concern
that people are having because when you
look at the cases of 173,000 China's
number one at 80,000 say eighty one
thousand by two it's been slowing down a
little bit
Italy's number two at twenty four
thousand seven forty-seven because they
didn't get ahead of it they kind of they
didn't take you that seriously and then
boom it's too
now they have that many death toll
iran's at fourteen thousand nine ninety
one spain's at eighty four eighty seven
ninety four then it sound Korea Germany
France us Switzerland then UK by the way
Mexico only has fifty three cases that's
why a lot of people are going to Mexico
because it's one of the safest places to
be today because coronavirus can't do
anything to Mexicans as of today death
toll by countries China's number one at
3213 Italy 1809 Iran 853 Spain 297
France 127 South Korea 75 u.s. 69 UK 35
Japan 27 Netherlands 20 again Mexico
death toll zero by the way the most
interesting number everybody's looking
at the following South Korea has 8200 36
cases and 75 death US has 3000 802 half
more than half the cases but only shy
from South Korea by six so why is that
what is South Korea you'll see a data
that will get through here for you to
take a look at but for those guys that
are from us this next data is for you to
see where America said by cases cases in
America number one is Washington Denis
New York then it's California then
Massachusetts Florida Colorado Louisiana
Georgia Illinois and Jersey and death
toll as for state number one is
Washington with 40 California 22 five of
its from a cruise line that came in
which would make it 27 but it's 22
California Florida sat for New York to
Virginia South Dakota Jersey Louisiana
Kansas Georgia Colorado all at once so I
gave you the cases I gave you the death
I give you an example of South Korean
where am I going with this here's one of
the biggest concerns that people are
having in America today because in
America hospital beds we have a total of
nine hundred and twenty-four thousand
one hundred hospital beds okay
of which around 600 to 650 is being used
which means we have around 300 thousand
available beds and that's concerning
because what if this outbreak taking
place and it goes so fast were in Italy
they don't have enough beds and enough
respiratory machines to give to people
so they're choosing who to give it to
don't give it to that old person give it
to this young person this person can
live longer that's what they're deciding
between in Italy on what to do in
America doesn't want to get to that
point because of hospital bed so now how
do we measure Hospital best the way we
measure hospital beds is how many
hospital beds a country has
per thousand people watch this data here
who's number one number one is Japan at
thirteen point all five beds per
thousand number two South Korea twelve
point two seven number three is Russia
805 then he got Germany at eight Austria
at seven point three two hungry at seven
point O two Czech Republic at six point
six thirty Pollan six point six to
Athena six point five six France at five
point nine eight and all the way
somewhere in the bottom US is at two
point eight and by the way Mexico is at
one point it just to kind of give you
some perspective because if this thing
spreads in Mexico they're also not so
good situation but US is at two point
eight bets per thousand but first of all
I just have a neighbor of mine that in
my office in Northridge his entire
business was hospital beds and he says
you have no idea how great business is
anybody in the hospital bed business
American hospitals are giving them calls
because they need bets today and they
need them fast so you sit there and you
think about it well how bad could this
thing be I mean it really when I'm
looking at the should I really be
worried the concern with this on why a
lot of people friends of mine on the
inside today's March 16 I got
information from the inside that there
may be a shutting down of any kind of
domestic travel Trump may be coming out
and making that announcement or they may
even have a full-on lockdown for a week
or two just to have this virus diet and
not create any momentum but I presume
that a lot of travel coming in from
Europe and Iran and any other countries
probably gonna be on lockdown for a long
time until they slow down their cases
even if US slows down and takes control
the cases and other countries or not
don't expect travel to be open to a lot
of other countries for quite some time
unless if they get a hold of it as well
unless if they get a hold of us but but
having said that let's look at compound
interest rule of 72 because if cases
double at this pace how bad could it be
remember just in January 29th it was
only five thousand nine hundred and
seventy four cases that's only six weeks
prior to today it's 173 thousand cases
from 59 74 so how bad is this double
effect this is the way I did the math I
took it if the number of cases double
every four days six days 10 days how bad
could it be in America this is what it
looks like
on February 4th we had 11 cases in us on
February 11th we had 14
On February 25th we had 59 February 25th
there's only three weeks prior today we
had 29 we had 59 we're at 3802 today
right now watching is March 3rd 125 from
March through to March 10th it goes two
thousand or four which is eight times
then it goes to March 16 3802
so I said let's double these cases every
four days every six days every 10 days
let's see what it looks like if you
double the 4,000 cases every four days
March 22 around 8,000 by April 17 we'll
crack a million by May 2nd we're at 16
million by May 22nd everyone in America
is coronavirus right now here's just
something to be thinking about if this
grows this way if it's every six days is
by June 30th everyone in America's
coronavirus and if it's every 10 days
its 914 everyone in America is gonna
have corona virus that is the big
concern that they have on how quickly
can spread that's why they're making
some of the big decisions that they're
making today so now the the biggest data
when I saw this my mind automatically
went to is how infectious is this
disease and how deadly is it compared to
some other diseases out there this is
what it's looking like when it comes out
to infectious the number they look at is
r0 which is a reproduction number
meaning per person that gets it how many
people can they give this virus to and
where does cobra drank coronavirus
ranked against others measles is number
one if you get it on average 12 to 18
people will get it
smallpox five to seven polio five to
seven eight is two to five Sarge's to
DIF I'm by the way some of these is
through sexual some of them is through
air some of them is through saliva spit
some of them is through touching pins
it's different methods of getting the
disease but it's some data that I'm
giving you here SARS is two to five
coronavirus is 1.4 to 3.9 which means
when you get it you can give it to 1.4
to 3.9 influencers 2 to 3 ebola is 1.5
to 2.5 in Merces point 3 2.8 if you do
get it how many people you can give it
to so that's the data of how infectious
it is how deadly it is number one was
Ebola at 50% number two is MERS at
thirty four point four percent number
three is smallpox 30 percent number four
SAR
that 9.6% number five is Kovac
coronavirus at 1% it's still 10 times
worse than seasonal flu but it's still
1% so out of a hundred people that get
it
one person guys now obviously they're
talking about the data that if you're
older it's worse but I'm giving you data
that I've out of a hundred one person
dies with this so look what is all this
stuff means you I got 10 names I want
you to follow up experts these are
former CDC directors this is Anthony
Fauci who's the head of national
institute of allergy and infectious
disease at the Institute of Health I got
I got top 10 names I want you to follow
I'll put the link in the a website that
I want to send you we just click on them
and follow them follow experts don't
follow people that are journalists who
need another story to sensationalize and
put fear in you because they need you to
go out and watch them regularly so
they've their way to get more
advertising dollars these guys don't
have to sell you anything they're just
telling you the fact these are good
people to follow so what does this mean
to you what does this mean to you and I
I did a webinar yesterday
and the way I started the webinar
everybody was wondering what's going I I
said there's three things you and I need
to be thinking about right now number
one is health
number two is finance number three is
replacing your income let me explain
number one is health when it comes down
to hell you have to be thinking about
elder elderly parents peers and siblings
spouse then kids then your friends where
your work unit elderly parents
grandparents peers brothers sibling
spouse kids right so when it comes down
to that you need to be doing your own
research on how to prepare for it how to
wash your hands teach your kids how to
wash your hand your family how to wash
your hands how do you get your immune
system to be stronger because if your
immune system is stronger you're in a
better place you know what to not touch
what to all of these things you need to
have a serious kind of like a State of
the Union type of a thing with your
family that's what you need to be doing
not with everybody which your own family
have that conversation that's number one
it's helped number two is finances look
you know the reality is there's a few
things going on today I remember in 2008
I've been in the financial industry
since 2001 when 9/11 happened as a
series 7 Broker 6630 all those licenses
and there's a big difference between a
market crashing or one and oh wait and
today or one no one could have predicted
it because it was two planes that flew
into World Trade Center and when that
came down it was war you couldn't have
said on 9/11 at such-and-such time 6:30
a.m. the Pacific Standard Time know you
said that it happened with shock wait a
minute what just happened brought the
entire country together right then in
greep got the best of everybody because
it's kind of Baltimore this this is
gonna be like this forever and no income
no assets and you can buy real estate
I'm gonna be a million I'm gonna be
worth 50 million 100 million no I don't
believe this stuff the dole channa is
always gonna buy the paper on the back
end we're gonna be okay
that was greed so the first one was
surprised the second one was greed this
one you can prepare for this is more
like a hurricane this is not something
that you couldn't be prepared for this
is a hurricane the data tells you it's
coming so the way you react to it could
protect your finances so for instance in
a way we had people that had their 401k
$700,000 they dropped a $250,000 market
tank 38% in a year and it was like why
I'm still gonna stay one more day one
more day one more day markets going down
depending on the age you are you have to
look at the way you've allocated your
funds you have to look at the way your
parents have allocated their funds and
you have to look at the way your
grandparents have allocated their funds
and how much equities they have today
because maybe somebody above 60s
shouldn't be in equities as much as they
are today because this is not going away
in the next week this is not going to
win next two weeks this is probably
going to be going on for the next four
eight sixteen weeks look this is the
data we have today all this data could
be changing tomorrow it could get worse
it could get better it could get all
that but you have to be prepared for
worst-case scenario and you have to
anticipate you have to prepare you have
to execute your strategy and be nimble
enough to make any kind of adjustments
if the numbers change the number one is
health
number two is finance number three is
replacing an income there are a lot of
people that are getting fired today and
many more will be there are many many
people that are going to get fired over
the next two four eight weeks because
companies are gonna sit there and say we
simply don't need people like Airlines
if Airlines shut down for four weeks
what are these what are they gonna be
doing what a pilot is gonna be doing
what are what are they gonna be doing
they can't go to another place and work
they have to be thinking about this if
you're working in hotel hotels good if
you're working at Apple Apple shut down
apples not gonna just pay salary to
everybody you have to be thinking about
what is going to be happening and you
have to think you still have to figure
out a way to make money on your own you
know Kyle was saying something earlier
today says do you think this is going to
cause us to get back to the point where
you
only really realize rely on your own
income I said that's how it's always
been
but we've conditioned people to think
they can rely on somebody else to
support them as a government people
gonna be forced to learn how to make
money today they're gonna be forced and
there's still opportunities out there
but you got to be thinking about as far
as investments and opportunities goes if
you're sitting on a lot of cash then X 4
8 16 weeks baseball cards real estate
you know collectible cars paintings
artifacts you know stocks and different
industries whether it's Airlines Hotel
Management so many different places
today to have if you've been disciplined
enough to have cash this is a great time
for you if you are so health finance
replacing your income now let's set that
part is that let me give you the final
thoughts on how I'm processing it we're
in LA and I'm in LA last week because I
have a board meeting and I go in with my
wife and I take my kids because it's
spring break for the kids I said we'll
go there I'm gonna visit offices like
always do and then we'll do our board
meeting on Monday and we'll go to church
we'll visit family will visit mom grab
everybody and it will come back great we
fly in one of my main board members says
I can't fly out why not I'm worried
about coronavirus really yes he's in
he's in his late 60s early 70s totally
understand totally get it
then another board member coming up from
Connecticut I'm concerned why if I come
to LA my mom and dad are gonna get
ticked if I don't go visit them and if I
visit them I don't want to give him
something I got my immune system can
handle but these guys are in their 80s
they can I get it no problem but I'm in
LA and I'm staying at Beverly Hilton
okay and I'm senator said okay what are
we gonna be doing I said babe we were
planning on going to Universal Studios
and visiting friends and family there
we're not gonna be doing our parks are
shutting down this need Disney World
this Universal Studios probably next so
we have to go back to Dallas we don't
need to stay here and it's raining
pouring she's like you won't tell the
kids I say yeah I said tico Dylan said I
got to talk to you guys and they come in
they're like all seriously lined up like
this you know and I said look we're not
going to Universal Studios today what
yeah we're not going to why not I said
there's a virus going around called
coronavirus and we haven't yet found a
solution for you now sometimes you have
a headache or you have a pain or an itch
and we put some ointment or something
that goes well yeah they don't yet have
the solution for this and once they
figure that things are going to go back
to normal
and then we'll see what happened so my
older son is like you know that do you
think we can come up with a solution for
coronavirus because what if we mix these
two different medicine his brain goes to
automatically trying to II just thinks
that way right and then after some
conversation they accepted a fact I said
if coronavirus refined a vaccine can we
come back to universes I said of course
we can come back awesome great can we go
watch a movie they want to watch a movie
so then I call my mom I call my that I
gave everybody the information on how to
be prepared because that's what you're
supposed to be doing then we came back
to Dallas but I told my wife on a flight
back I said babe what is the only way
this is gonna slow down what is your
limit it's gonna slow down so we came
back the first thing I did Saturday I
got and I came to the office early in
the morning I was at the office I spent
seven eight nine hours just researching
overnight I left the office at 7:30 on
Saturday night 8 o'clock on Saturday
night after y'all day so pull up all
this data I was worried about how
infectious it is I was worried about how
bed leaders I was worried about the
hospital beds I'm kind of looking at how
it's gonna be fit doubles and how we
need to be prepared for it but I told my
wife I said baby here's probably the
best thing we need to be thinking about
what's that we have to accept the fact
that many people are gonna get Crono
virus it could be somebody in our family
it could be some of our friends could be
some of our co-workers the odds are
people are gonna get it because of these
cases going to millions if it's at 173
and it was at 5600 just a couple months
ago just a few weeks ago this thing is
gonna go into millions in no time and we
just have to accept it's kind of like
well people have this and people have
that and then from there you have to
study people that on quarantine that are
going through a recovery mode and we
have to see what they're doing they're
gonna give us data on Intel and when we
get that data and Intel because they're
saying right now it's gonna take 18
months to get a vaccine for this some
are saying fal'cie already found
something but nobody knows because every
day we're learning new things about this
I said but I'm relying on innovators and
problem-solvers and entrepreneurs to fix
this when Trump got up any announcement
he says Google's here seen yes to CEO
Walmart's here that's all the
entrepreneurs that are coming to get a
figuring out a way to solve this problem
because I've told you for many many
years
entrepreneurs are gonna solve world's
problems and I've told you cash is king
and today's times validates both even
the administration is really leaning on
innovators to find a solution for this
and they're getting the scientists and
the brilliant minds to see what can we
do about this kind of stuff but in every
single back time Yona have been a part
of when I was in Iran we're getting
bombed on and one moment it was bad it's
just like it seems like fifteen of them
hit in a span of five minutes and you
were just hearing all these and we're
under the stairs we're hiding here
what's a four-story building were under
the stairs because this is metal
every time the buildings would come down
you would look the safe the place that
would always stay is under the stairs
all the way at the bottom so we're
hiding there me my mom my dad my sister
and here's what I there's a six year I
remember till today I look up on my dad
and I'm looking at him and I'm like how
come he's not worried not crying my
mom's cry my sister I'm calm
or what worked if the man of the
household is not worried huh maybe I
shouldn't be and we thought were gonna
die and we can control anything we went
to kadaj bomb Rashed bomb Bandera
palpable and every city we went to they
were bombing so it's not like it's a
surprise attack right it's like 9/11 but
I looked at him and he gave me strength
fast-forward 35 years later I remembered
that as a 41 year old with three kids
and a wife and a family and two
companies I'm running I'm thinking about
that moment so for you what does this
mean to you I don't know why it is
crisis tends to give birth to new
leaders I don't know why it is crisis
tends to give birth to new heroes and
Families everybody today is panicking
many people are panicking today whether
they're de nieve the responsible the
ignorant or they're panicking today but
also every family every community every
country every city every country company
has somebody that comes in with data and
they bring strength and confidence with
execution they're those end up coming
out of this and everyone leans on them
as these are the leaders so this is a
chance for you to be in your family a
leader in your company a leader in your
community a leader a leader doesn't mean
they don't do due diligence a leader
doesn't mean they're not looking at how
seriously this this is not a hoax this
is real a part of a leaders
responsibility is to go get the data for
them subsidy can send it to people that
are on them so if you do that and things
eventually end up getting better we can
look back and say wow man we learned a
lot from this we can definitely no
longer have 2.8 best 4000 we can
definitely not be we can definitely we
have to be prepared for these times and
we're going to get smarter so again
the data I'm giving us as of today March
16th things could change and if it
requires me to do another video I may do
another video but there's a couple
things I want you to that promise you
early on I have something for your
number one if you haven't watched the
first corner virus video I did watch
this because it explains the difference
between a pandemic and an epidemic and
it explains the biggest pandemics of all
time and it explains how the economy has
done in US and worldwide six months
after a pandemic and 12 months after a
pandemic that's a lot of great data
click on this link to go watch a video
the second thing is if you want to get
all these updates on a website on a
daily basis you can go to one place and
see which articles you ought to read and
which people to follow the ten names
that I have here to follow that are
giving you info we just click on them
and go to their Twitter account click on
a link below for those you guys that are
not in the States it'll take you to
subscribe to the newsletter if you're in
u.s. simply text coronavirus two three
one oh three four zero one one three two
three one oh three four zero one one
three two text coronavirus two three one
oh three four zero one one three two
instantly you're gonna get the link with
all the information can go follow it and
you can texas any dates going to be the
most updated or linked out to be sent
over to you and again if you haven't
subscribed to the channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody
take care well bye
[Music]